it's great to welcome to the program
today henry giroux who is the chaired
professor of scholarship in the public
interest at mcmaster university his most
recent book is race politics and
pandemic pedagogy published this year by
bloomsbury it's so great to have you on
i appreciate your time today
i'm delighted to be here
so you know there there's been many
political analyses made of this
authoritarian slide that we've seen that
we could say led up to the election of
donald trump in 2016 but then also was
further fomented by the election of
donald trump in 2016.
i'm interested uh to hear from you
more your thoughts on the cultural
aspect of this and how far back you
think the the kind of catalysts for this
slide go and how we should sort of be
conceiving of it
i mean i i think we've seen uh
political and
cultural extremism in the in the united
states it has a long history
uh i mean we've seen it with the
mccarthy period we saw with the red
scare and then of course there's the
legacy of colonization i mean there's
the
wiping out of indigenous populations
there's jim crow there's slavery
and i think that one of the things that
this country has failed to confront is
not only that legacy but how it tends to
reappear in different forms in different
historical moments and i think that
where i see an enormous turning point in
the united states is in the 1970s
all of a sudden it seems to me there's
there's a counter-revolution emerging
against the 60s against the
democratization of the social order
against the attempt to in in some way
eliminate massive inequalities and
wealth and power and with reagan
something happens and what happens is
there's an enormous shift in cultural
values and that shift moves away from
supporting the public good to basically
in many ways destroying it and claiming
that the market now should be the
template not simply for judging the
economy or managing the economy but for
all of social life this has an
enormously destructive
uh consequence it seems to me in the
united states and it begins to give rise
to far right wing movements who for the
most part hate the public good hate the
common good and all of a sudden find
themselves on the side of reproducing
echoes of history
that are pretty dangerous whether we're
talking about right-wing extremism
racial purity misogyny militarism
ultra-nationalism i mean all these
forces begin to come into
become very visible and come to the
service in light of the increasing
misery that i call neoliberalism or
gangster capitalism produces as a result
of the 1980s when i when i spoke to noam
chomsky a couple of months ago the
political points that he thought were
relevant in that period you're talking
about
uh include as a reaction to the civil
rights movement um the establish the
establishment of the war on drugs for
example um uh the fight against roe v
wade and that some of these points led
to what the republican party became in
the early 90s under newt gingrich and
then we can sort of like follow the
political line culturally though what
was it about those things that were
happening prior to during and after the
70s that kind of changed this american
right wing i mean what you begin to see
culturally a couple of things
ideologically you see
a an
ideology of self-interest
reproduced in many ways in celebrity
culture and consumerism
citizenship takes on a very different
form culturally after the 1980s all of a
sudden the obligations of citizenship
citizenship have to do with consumerism
the mall becomes the temple of of the
state so to speak but you also see
something else you see a rise in what i
call the punishing state and a decline
of the social state and with that comes
a number of cultural apparatuses that
begin to reinforce what i call the most
insidious
cultural aspect of neoliberalism or
gangster capitalism and that is the
individualization of problems
everything becomes privatized all
problems are a matter of individual
responsibility and what that means
culturally is it becomes increasingly
difficult for people to translate
private troubles into larger systemic
considerations so the social begins to
collapse now what happens as a result of
that culturally what happens is you have
the war on drugs you have of course
clinton's uh war on the welfare state
you you have the southern strategy i
mean all of things all of these things
combine a question of racial purity and
what i call white supremacy with the
logic of capitalism somebody has to be
blamed
and who has to be blamed are immigrants
or blacks
or young people you know all those
groups that are relatively powerless in
the face of this overwhelmingly
political and cultural apparatus now
david there's something else and i think
the other side of this is what we have
to understand is that education takes a
radical turn in the 1980s it
increasingly becomes privatized
commodified
undermined defunded and all of a sudden
we're not talking about educating people
to be critical engaged citizens anymore
we're talking about them we're talking
about teachers to teach with the test
yep this runs through a whole range of
presidents i mean the republican and the
democratic parties
both share a notion of education as
anti-intellectual destroys the civic
imagination
uh
imposes what i call a pedagogy of
repression and basically produce and
increases an anti-intellectualism that
is in the schools and in the larger
cultural apparatus
second point don't confuse schooling
with education
schooling is an institution that we know
of public hire but education takes place
in other spheres
the the the new social media the digital
media the rise of what i call an
oracular image-based culture and these
are largely controlled by the right and
so you have this tsunami of
anti-intellectualism right-wing nonsense
lies misinformation conspiracy theories
emerging since the 1970s
and you find their endpoint in trump
i want to get back to the education
piece because
i have so many notes about it one small
thing that i was thinking of in your
your cultural idea of the kind of
individualization of problems is this
related to the gun issue in the united
states in this specific sense that
unlike in many other countries
too many people in the u.s see guns as a
way to solve problems that are that are
really systemic problems but they say i
will solve individually this problem
with a firearm
i think it's a brilliant analysis and i
think it's right on target i i think
that basically when you individualize
problems you say that people have to
take are both responsible for those
problems individually and have the right
to engage them in ways that suggest that
the government is the enemy of freedom
rather than something that could be
useful in dealing with these issues the
the other side of this is that
when you individualize problems in this
way
you can't address them systemically so
you begin to increasingly criminalize
social problems
so you know if youth for instance acting
out in schools you know the principal
doesn't come down and say hey come on
let's talk you call the police and all
of a sudden you have little
five-year-olds in handcuffs in
kindergarten uh so it seems to me with
this increasing criminalization of
social problems you have a notion of
freedom emerging that is completely
removed from this any notion of social
responsibility right a notion of freedom
that simply says i can do what i want
self-interest is all that matters uh all
problems are individualized this is what
i call the individualization of the
social and in the social sphere and the
social contract and the social good
and the public good david begin to
collapse
we lose those sites where people can
understand the interconnections that
make a democracy possible couple that
with an education and schooling system
that basically produces new forms of
civic illiteracy and you don't have a
democracy anymore because you can't have
a democracy without informed citizens
so on education i frequently will get
calls from viewers
i mean listen talking about
individualizing things i will get calls
from viewers who say
my cousin my uncle whoever
they've fallen for false beliefs about
vaccines they've fallen for false
beliefs about
it doesn't matter what but they're not
thinking they've just they've fallen for
it how do i talk them out of it and i
struggle to say anything other than you
know at the individual level
it can take weeks or months of really
getting someone to re-examine their
beliefs that's like a retail strategy
it's not a wholesale strategy my
instinct is
it's too late and and really if people
learned critical thinking and media
literacy and epistemology in middle
school
we prevent this from even happening in
the first place to some degree not with
everybody but maybe we give people the
tools to not fall into this in the first
place is that a fair critique of of of
at least a piece of what's wrong with
the educational or schooling system as
you call it today
no i think it's an important piece i
mean it's foundational in that the way
we educate people says something about
the kind of agents we produce and the
kind of future we want and it seems to
me education in schooling in that sense
is very long term i think the other side
of this is that you know how do we talk
about taking control of these cultural
apparatuses that basically are this
imagination machines i mean we're not
just talking about uh how do you say it
the ability to get people to think
critically or rationally or to be able
to engage other positions that's
important but we're also talking about
larger systemic apparatuses that need to
be challenged by people like us like in
social movements and reproduced in ways
that give people the opportunity to be
able to recognize that the most
fundamental questions are not whether
they're falling for lies but what kind
of future do they want for their
children do they want health care that's
free do they want to be in debt
for the rest of their lives critical
consciousness matters but it has to
translate ideas have to translate and be
wedded to power and it seems to be when
we remove the question of power from the
question of insight we fall into a trap
that we unconsciously reproduce that we
may want to stay away from and that is
to say well just talk to each other no
i'm sorry it's not about just talking
about each other it's about changing the
very institutions that have put us there
in the first place and that's not just
the burden of people who are confused
that's that's a political obligation
that we all have to engage in with those
people hopefully so in that sense i mean
when when you hear these very
superficial narratives of part of the
problem is
left and right don't engage anymore or
the the dialogue has coarsened this type
of stuff
is does that not really strike you as
particularly important that's a
diversion i find that as a political
diversion because it doesn't deal with
fundamental questions like look what's
the result of massive inequality in the
united states and where does it come
from right what is it what does it mean
when some people are trading medicine
for for
you know for food stamps you know what
does it mean when schools are collapsing
you know that's not a matter of whether
the right and left can talk to each
other that's a matter of how do we talk
about democracy as a country if we're
going to take democracy seriously and
what are the forces that are undermining
it these are very different kinds of
questions what does it mean to live in a
country where economic activity is
removed from social cost what's the
consequence of that and how does it bear
down on our lives the last thing is that
we have to be able
shame is a terrible pedagogical tool
i think shaming people does nothing but
just reinforce the worst divisions and i
think the real question here for all of
us is how do we begin to use a language
in which people can recognize themselves
in which we can shift consciousness in
ways in which people can say yeah that's
that makes sense to me without putting
their identities on trial we need a
language that's rigorous accessible in
order to make something meaningful to
make it critical to make it
transformative can you give an example
of that in terms of
on any issue could you give an example
of the wrong way that the language is
being used and then how it could be
improved i i mean i i think in talking
to people that for instance are dealing
with schools people will often see
schools are failing it's terrible i
think we should home school and one of
the questions i always raise is that if
school is so crucial do you think school
is crucial to to democracy to your life
for your children yes then why is it
being defunded
schools aren't failing
they've been defunded i mean the problem
is not that schools are failing the
problem is that they actually serve a
very important purpose in society and we
have to ask ourselves why do people want
to destroy them and why do some people
have access and you don't what can we do
to make schools matter in your community
how would we do that together how would
we speak to that how would we make
schools more rich what resources do we
need what policies what does it mean to
get on a school board can we do that in
order to change your curriculum so that
you have for instance free meals for
your kid in the morning kid is starving
can't learn sorry you know right
teachers who have 47 kids in a class
can't learn so i think when we start to
deal with particulars and make them
resonate with the very conditions that
people can recognize in their lives we
make something meaningful to make it
blah blah i'll give you one last example
people often say to me why don't you
come to the united states come back and
i said well would you get national
health care
and i said what do you mean i said look
i've had two knee surgeries i didn't
have to pay to pay i don't pay a pen a
cent
you know my drugs are basically free
i can walk into a corner a doctor's
office a drop-in center and get free
medical care and they don't believe this
stuff
and you know when i say you know most
debt in the united states is now due to
medical expenses right
i mean you know and i know just recently
at one hospital i think in tennessee
charged somebody six thousand seven
hundred and fifty dollars for three
tests for coronavirus you know this this
sort of thing has to be talked about and
illustrated and then in some way
connected to people's lives in terms of
um the language that we're seeing to
sort of shift back a little bit to our
to the earlier part of the conversation
uh federico finkelstein from the new
school regularly a fellow argentinian i
i might add um he uh has written a lot
about the analogous language between you
know past authoritarians and dictators
and the kind of modern language of trump
etc
two-part question one to what degree do
you see the language as analogous and
two
are these politically uh astute
comparisons to be making from a
practical perspective even if they are
true i think they're absolutely
practical i know his work and i know him
and i and i think that if we can't learn
from the past as the old saying goes
we're more than doomed to to repeat it
we might as we might find ourselves in
places that we never could imagine could
happen we might find ourselves faced
with the unthinkable and i think that
when we talk about ultra nationalism we
talk about militarism i mean we talk
about for instance the 1930s and the 40s
one of the things that we have to make
clear is simply because
fashion what i call fascist politics
emerges but doesn't present itself in an
exact replica does not mean it doesn't
exist it means that it's always in
remission but tends to emerge in
different forms
and i think that what we have to look at
are the signals we have to look at the
similarities and certainly he's
absolutely right as is timothy schneider
jason stanley and a number of others who
were saying hey look look at this
language lies how central with the
question of lies in for instance in the
nazi regime racial purity racial
cleansing what does that tell us where
did that go in the 1930s and 40s
the appeal to militarism hyper
masculinity the attack on women's bodies
the attack on others the friend enemy
distinction
uh the the ongoing attempt to demonize
people and to claim that the public's
fear is only for white people my god i
mean if that doesn't conjure up an image
of the past and echoes of the past that
we should take seriously then they don't
if you don't believe in that analysis
you're going to have to end up in a cell
somewhere before you actually realize
right that fascist politics is here
alive well and throbbing think about the
january 6th
attack
i mean even robert o paxton who first
was the great historian of fascism who
said no trump is not a fascist has come
out recently and said i was wrong
i'm sorry the line has been crossed we
are basically now in a fascist culture
and fascist politics is on the rise of
the united states and represents a very
dangerous moment
uh the latest book from henry giroux is
race politics and pandemic pedagogy
published by bloomsbury we've been
speaking with henry drew chaired
professor for scholarship in the public
interest at mcmaster university it's
been so great having you on i can't tell
you how much i appreciate your time
today
oh thank you david it's a pleasure